what up guys welcome to another episode
of pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start like the video on your
way in and subscribe to the channel also
sign up to our email list as we can be
kicked off any day and get yourself a
new piece of merch we have our whale
merch and women shouldn't vote
sweatshirts make sure you get one today
okay so the first topic I wanted to talk
about is growing up you always hear as a
woman that you deserve the world you
deserve more you are a queen you are
beautiful you are amazing and we even
have phrases like princess treatment why
do average women need to be treated like
princesses it doesn't make sense to me
and what it leads to is entitled women
that think they deserve I mean we
reacted to an obese woman the other day
saying she deserves a 500K man this
delusion and oftentimes what starts as
good intentions leads to women being
alone and single so I wanted to further
talk about the conversation that I was
having with Tim p yesterday it's
interesting because guys I am dedicated
to finding out what is true about the
world and overwhelmingly when men have
the option to cheat they tend to now I
know you guys are saying Pearl but Pearl
but Pearl this is a bad thing men
shouldn't cheat my opinions on men
cheating do not change the facts of the
matter when men have three things looks
money and Status they tend to cheat
high-end businessmen are known for
cheating Rich NBA players NFL players
are known for cheating Hollywood is
known for cheating if we go into these
relationships which let's be honest most
women will not qualify for those men
anyway but we tell those women that you
should demand a Brad Pit and you should
expect loyalty from him and if he does
slip up ever he is evil and he is evil
and terrible and you are amazing so I
thought of the one and only Brad Pit so
as you guys know Brad Pit and Jennifer
andison used used to be married they
were a power couple they were beautiful
in the early 2000s oh my gosh they were
such a beautiful couple and Brad Pit
cheated on Jennifer Aniston with
Angelina Jolie now you could argue maybe
he did get his feelings involved with
her obviously he married her later but
at surface level Brad Pit did not
divorce anist Aniston divorced Brad Pit
and the question is now is Jennifer
Aniston in a better place so Jennifer
Aniston opens up about feeling kind of
alone other relationship struggles this
is in 2023 now guys Jennifer Inon is a
National Treasure she is beautiful she
could have had any guy on the planet and
she got the exact man she wanted I mean
what woman wouldn't want to be with Brad
Pit but Society told her she should
expect loyalty from a guy like that and
unfortunately men like that do not give
out loyalty you will not get it and so
if you get the Brad Pit of your town and
that's what you want to do instead of an
average guy why do we tell women to live
in delusion instead of looking at what
men have always done throughout history
Kings have always had multiple men Kings
have always had multiple women now guys
my feelings I am a Catholic I do not
think that is a good thing but what I
have noticed is we demonize one type of
sin when men cheat they are the end all
Beall they and Tim P said you just
surround yourself with bad people and I
didn't even know I'm going to actually
wait let me let me get this let me get
this I want to I want to quote this
exactly
because I have this opinion Tim P says
to me I want I want to get this exact
quote apparently I'm just the worst I am
just the worst he says Pearl is just
another woman that hates men because I'm
not blind guys guys I I can't not see
what's in front of me I I'm not I'm not
blind and I refuse I could I could look
good if I wanted I could virtue signal
and say men should never cheat but my
feelings about it doesn't change the
facts and so many times women believe
that our feelings about something should
change what is reality I refuse to bend
reality for what is true she sees them
inherently untrustworthy and lacking
discipline no I just see human nature is
human nature I
mean I I think you know most men have
never been in the position where they
have eights nines and tens chasing after
them I think that's going to be very
tempting for a guy over a long period of
time marriage gets boring and lame and
when a hot 20 something year old comes
up to a guy not every guy especially in
the society we're in now which is most
men are not religious it's going to be
tough for him to it would be tough for a
religious guy to turn that down now this
does not say that I advocate for it this
does not say that I think it's good but
I think we have to have an honest
conversation as women about choices and
tradeoffs there is a tradeoff for going
for the top 10 20% of men and that may
be the tradeoff and if that happens what
will you do and the interesting thing is
I actually advocate for working through
infidelity I think the kids are more
important than you and you should work
through infidelity at all costs
especially because cheating for men and
women is different um okay so then she
said she just like I said to fresh and
fit surrounds herself with the the worst
people and assumes everyone is bad so
see this goes this goes to a personal
attack now he's saying Pearl your
opinions are so gosh awful that you just
think everyone is bad no guy that I know
in my personal life cheats I I don't
even I don't know anybody that cheat but
I am not stupid to the fact that men
that tend to get the
opportunity more on a balance of
probabilities will do it and the other
thing I'm not blind to is you never know
what happens behind closed doors so I
could virtue signal now imagine I was I
was at advising Jennifer Aniston back in
the day I could virtue signal and say
Jennifer Jennifer Jennifer leave him you
deserve the world that is a man that's
so terrible and has no morals or I could
say you know what he's human he's in a
tough position where women are chasing
him
247 maybe you should give the guy some
Grace now again this is never going to
be a popular opin opinion amongst men or
women but typically what I noticed is
the way that men signal to women that
they are attractive as a long-term mate
I see this a lot men that don't have
looks tend to get money and then what
they do is they signal to women they're
an attractive long-term mate because
they have money and they will be loyal
in a way that they can compete with the
guys that are just hot I'm I look for
patterns okay guys you know I asked the
question is Jennifer andison in a better
place now that she left Brad Pit because
she expected faithfulness from a man
with looks money and Status am I the bad
guy for asking this question it's like
women we don't get to have it all and if
you want to go for the Brad pits of the
world that is fine but they come with
Brad Pit problems and so many times I
I'm so tired of the Steve Harvey types
pandering to us and saying you deserve
it all if you can find it all I'm happy
for you you know go you go girl unicorns
exist but that doesn't change the fact
that they are unicorns men with the
combination of the three that is what
they tend to do and you know then Larry
says I mean she could have 99% of guys
if she wanted and the question is if she
could have the guy she wanted she
wouldn't be by herself I would guess
that the guy she wanted was Brad Pit but
she wanted a faithful Brad Pit and they
do not exist they are not real the
comment says Nope ruined her limited
time that money can't buy childless yeah
and she could have had a superhuman baby
with with Brad
Pit that would have been like the most
attractive child ever applying a unicorn
scenario to pop populace doesn't seem
sciency what's the data set you're using
to have this perception so again guys
you could look at data and data does
show that men that are richer tend to
cheat more good-looking men tend to
cheat more I I mean this is just common
sense but even without looking at data
again the Brad pits of the world fine
Brad Pit is exceptionally attractive but
there is the Brad Pit of your hometown
the best looking guy in your hometown
the best looking guy at your school the
best looking guy at work again men with
the option to have a tendency to and
just because I don't agree with it
morally it doesn't make it untrue and
I've Just Seen women demonize male sin
you know I thought about this like
what's worse a nagging wife or a
cheating husband and I had some comments
say to me Pearl Pearl but that is not
the same they are totally different and
I thought to myself if you get cheated
on and don't find out you never find out
you never know so it doesn't affect fect
you in any way but a nagging wife that
that affects you every day like women we
are not these innocent creatures that do
no wrong you know I I think at some
point we ex they men extend Grace to us
for a lot a lot of us are overweight a
lot of us didn't bring the sexual Purity
to the table that our grandmothers and
great-grandmothers brought a lot of us
were not raised to be wives and men put
up with it and they deal with us but
when men sin in a more masculine way
there is no Grace for them and Tim said
something along the lines of these are
men with no honor and can't stick to
their word and it's like are you perfect
so you you've stuck to your word every
single time really like I just can't
stand this virtue signaling and I'll
never I'll never win these arguments
because these are uncomfortable truths
uncomfortable truths are not fun to say
but I I can't I'm not blind to what's in
front of me so a lot of times modern
women want on it all we want to make
money on only fans and then we want to
just sell our butthole for
$9.99 and then get a husband
after but a lot of times what isn't
spoken about is the cost that comes with
the average only fans model makes
roughly 500 a month she doesn't make
much I I think it's actually less than
that I have to look it up but so I saw
this crazy video of a woman talking
about I I just need to show the video
woman talking about her experience on o
to me having my only fans account I had
had this subscriber almost since the
beginning he had spent around $2,000
Australian dollars bought every single
thing that I sent him we chatted every
day on there and he had a very specific
username that was not a like
automatically generated one or anything
like that and an account with the same
username had viewed my Tik Tok profile
when I could see who was viewing it at
the time
um and yeah so I had the exact same
username and it said from your contacts
and my heart just sank into my stomach
and I was like I don't have that many
phone numbers in my phone I know who
this person is and he has spent this
much money on my account seen everything
and I just sort of went into Super
detective mode and I said I need to find
out who this is I went through all of
the contacts in my phone I crossed out
anybody who had a established Tik Tok
account and crossed out the people that
said invite to Tik Tok and I was left
with six names it was a couple of guys
from school one girl from school
someone's mom and my stepdad and I had
just thought okay it could be those guys
but I feel like they would have told me
like they always messag me happy
birthday it's not going to be them it's
not going to be my girlfriend it's not
going to be this mother it has to be my
stepdad wow so I went out on a limb and
messaged the account on only fans and I
said I know who this is and he responded
saying who question mark babe you don't
know and I then hit back pretty quickly
and I said you need to tell her before
my sister and I do and with her being
your mom yeah being my mom and within 2
minutes I got a text message from my
stepdad saying Tay you're free to talk
so I want to talk about how the sin of
the mother is passed down to the
children I have interviewed so many only
fans models and so many times they come
from a home either with a weak father or
no dad at all now you have a woman who
is sexually irresponsible to the point
where she brought home a man that is
sexually going after her daughters now
when you're a kid your house and home is
supposed to be the place where you feel
free where you it is supposed to be a
safe haven and this woman has grown up
with a man that has been looking at her
like that from a young age that is
disgusting this this is some of the
consequences that come from out of order
Mur bringing random men into the home
women this this is like the greatest sin
of all sins bringing home a random man
to raise your daughters I really do not
believe that women should even try to
remarry I I really don't I really think
you made your bed you should give the
kid to the dad because imagine being
that woman's ex-husband I mean it's very
clear that whoever was her dad was not
in her life because she wouldn't be on o
laugh her he wasn't a strong enough
influence to keep her out of that
direction and her stepfather clearly was
encouraging it and this is actually
disgusting but it also shows that the
stepdad is one of the most likely people
to abuse the kid okay so the comment
section comes in and says a nightmare of
One's Own creation yeah this whole story
is just messed up um she won't be
getting any sympathy making of is
immoral and immoral meets immoral right
exactly the audacity she had has to
assert any sort of moral superiority and
the crowd is just as hypocritical as she
is
yeah no
actually I mean and that's the thing
they all comfort her when really it's
like you made your bed you got to lie in
it but what I want I want you guys to
notice the dynamic that tends to happen
when you meet of models there's two
things it's either a weak father or no
father at all and typically you can tell
it's a weak father because he doesn't
disown her and often times the mother
starts encouraging her to go on off and
the dad supports it and what does that
tell us usually when there's an outof
order household it's because the woman
believes she's above the man or leads
the household okay so um I saw I wanted
to point out a dynamic that we have from
Megan the stallion so Megan the stallion
is the popular Entertainer rapper and
social media star she pressed um she
famously uh arguably me too Tory Lanes
now Tory Lanes is in in jail um because
she said that he shot her the evidence
was very weak but somehow he he's still
in jail anyways so Megan the stallion is
known for sleeping around the industry
many rappers entertainers ball players
have said they have slept with Megan the
stallan and she was talking about it on
a live and how she is going to
be stingy with the cooe cat in the
future all
right it's like nobody be listening to
my music they be like
Megan the stallion I cannot believe she
likes to have
sex I cannot believe making the stallion
[Laughter]
[__] we shall
be no but I am turning over you know a
new
leave and I'm stingy with a Cy
cat I'm not a freak
anymore
oh my
God I'm done I'm done with the shreds so
toxic in the
streets I'm tired of the
streets okay so this tends to happen to
women around late 20s early 30s where
they suddenly find God now I'm not
disputing that some Wom women genuinely
do find God around this time but
oftentimes women use this as a mating
strategy in order to compete for men
they no longer have the looks that they
used to when they were younger so they
have to prioritize other things like a
relationship with God and the problem is
and and she didn't say God or church in
this obviously um but you know she said
stingy with the Coe cotie cat um and
basically women Reach This phase around
27 to 32 roughly years old it depends on
on the looks of the woman where she
realizes she cannot compete in the
sexual Marketplace like she used to um
so the comment section had a lot of
suitors for Megan I'm sure that said
they're really excited to compete for
this cootie cat that she is stingy with
uh you can't be stingy with the
community
cat Megan the mileage and it's great to
hear that Megan the stallion is focusing
on her well-being and making positive
changes in her life setting boundaries
and being more selective about who she
shares her personal time and energy with
is a healthy step towards self-care and
personal growth so around this age this
is when women tend to pick the safer guy
um and you can see this in with dating
app data based on like what we select
for in our early 20s it tends to be
things like nice car nice watch uh late
20s to early 30s it tends to be more
long-term retirement house um like early
20s women tend to pick more for a
lifestyle later 20s early 30s women tend
to pick more for long-term security um
and the problem is men do not and ladies
I'm just going to explain this men can't
stand this they cannot stand the idea of
paying more for a product that other men
got for free now I know you might not
view yourself as a product I I totally
get it but this is how men view it uh
the idea that other men have you know
done the commun the community cooe
cat I don't know um with virtually no
effort and now she would ask the next to
put in a lot of effort is rough men men
do not like this um and men will always
put up with it but this is why myON and
them have rules like if she doesn't
sleep with you on the first date go to
the next chick because she has done it
for somebody and the problem is even
women that maybe this is their you know
standard doubt it but sorry don't cut
that and even even women you know even
women that aren't like that um
unfortunately with the marketplace the
men all kind of of assume there is
something in this modern world okay so
the next story um yesterday was
Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving
everybody and by the way this Christmas
season you can also get yourself a women
shouldn't vote Christmas sweatshirt the
link to that is in the comment section
and the description but in honor of
Thanksgiving there is a trans Tik tocker
asking people to donate to his fund for
surgery to get his chopped off okay
let's pull it it's Thanksgiving week you
want to start up a little controversy
the bar has been raised this year new
tattoo is not going to do it oh you got
your nose pierced so did Grandma well
maybe I'll tell everyone who I voted for
and who I'm definitely not voting for
they know they
know no you really want to make a splash
at the turkey table this
year I'll tell you what you need to
do donate to a trans woman's go fundme
for gender affirming
surgery and watch heads roll
well but I don't really have any trans
friends I'll be your
friend hey
bestie there's a link in my
bio minimum donation is just $5
$5 to make Thanksgiving
hory I think that's worth
it
yeah yeah I think that's worth
it don't you no I don't think it's worth
it is this person crazy some of these
people are just bums all they're trying
to do is take advantage of a situation
and get some money if you want to
mutilate yourself please do that on your
own dollar and stop marketing to the
children on Tik Tok to give money for
your surgery and cause a bunch of
controversy at the dinner table please
please please stop this is just
insaneness and I don't need it anymore
and this is the problem what you see on
these apps is you see see a lot of older
predatory men women marketing stuff to
children to get them to be a part of
their movement and guys guys this is why
you could have a conservative family but
if you are not monitoring what they are
doing and watching and consuming online
you have no idea what Rabbit Hole they
will go down and as your parent it is
important that you are responsible and
watch what media your kids are consuming
so the so the comment section way and
this guy had my exact thought typical
lib tries to get everyone else to pay
for their wants wishes and desires see
this person was trying to become a woman
and so as a woman women love free
stuff he's already he's already starting
for the love of God please open the
asylums again yes yes bring them back um
why do they always beg for money is it
because they're jobless and spending way
too much time on social media yes I want
to I want maybe that should be my next
t-shirt drop get a a job get a job
please ladies ladies ladies ladies
please stop accepting these benefits for
being a single mother please ladies
please stop accepting these free dates
free [__] from men that you have no
interest in please ladies please stop
expecting men to pay for you when you to
get a free ride for your entire life
please ladies get off of the government
benefits please ladies stop crying about
these tampon taxes please ladies stop
crying for equal pay when you don't want
to do equal work I am tired of hearing
about it get a job get a job and if
you're not going to get a job kiss my
ass and stop crying crying that's gonna
be my new t-shirt get a
job okay and these lunatics these
lunatics are not only trying to Market
to your kids on Tik Tok they're in the
public school system
there have been so many lunatics that
are teaching children it is absolutely
insane you have people telling children
that they need to be liberal from a
young age they push their own ideology
onto their children when your political
beliefs as a teacher should have nothing
to do with what you tell the kids kids
are innocent beings their family should
be the first ones to put their ideology
onto the kids you were supposed supposed
to grow up with your family values not
whatever crazy batshit teacher is
teaching your kids and teachers have a
terrible reputation in the dating Market
I've heard terrible things about dating
teachers from the men so if the men are
dating the teachers and saying they're
mentally
unstable how do we trust these CH these
kids going to public school and that is
why you have seen this surge of people
that are homeschooling their kids they
are done with this [__] so there is a
video going viral of a teacher
claiming that her kindergarten students
are nonbinary and use they them
pronouns just saying if my 5 to
seven-year-old art students can
correctly use they them pronouns for
their peers and accept non-binary kids
without batting an eye adults should
[__] be able to do
it what is wrong with you what what on
Earth is wrong with you why are you
confusing children at a young age
children are so impressionable so a
couple of weeks ago or months ago I had
a opair reunion where basically my old
opars from like when I was a kid came
back and they brought all of their kids
together and it was so awesome and
amazing it was so cute and I was I was
playing with the kids and it was so
funny because I would tell them to do
something I would be like kids kids jump
they would all jump I'd be like kids
kids we're GNA run they would all run I
be like kids kids tag and the funny
thing is kids will do exactly what you
tell them they are so impressionable
they all look up to like it is the most
adorable joyous thing in the world and
and how evil is it that you take their
innocent and you throw your agenda down
their throat everybody starts off
innocent and these
disgusting people that are mentally ill
a lot of them and addicted to social
media put their ideology onto innocent
children so the comment section weighs
in how do kindergarteners know any but
what the teacher tells them exactly this
isn't teaching but IND ration
homeschooling is the only way to protect
them yeah and you used to be able to
send your kids to public schools and
they would get a decent education but
now they just turn into a raging leftist
and if they don't get it from their
teachers a lot of times they get it from
their peers January Little John because
they are being groomed into Confusion by
virtue s signaling Predators like this
one children look to adults in their
lives for guidance and Truth they are
highly impressionable be careful of who
you are allowing to guide your children
he's says remember this moles when you
hear people say teachers need to be paid
more no they've been doing a worse job I
mean IQ has dropped in the last hundred
years and this is the thing when women
go into an industry at large it becomes
wo I just want think Corporate America
when women went into Corporate America
what happened woke when women go into
any industry they start saying you can't
say it like that it's how you say it and
they get more and more woke women women
women keep your ideologies at home we
don't want hear it children do not need
your ideology shoved down their throat
their parents should be the primary
person influencing them not you in your
woke agenda okay so um I wanted to show
a clip of Kim Kardashian and Northwest
Northwest so the story of Kim yay and
North is is very interesting we have
watched yay be demonized for the past
couple of years for trying to get access
to his children and being the primary
influence in his kids life and it's
really interesting to watch North be
raised in front of the entire world I I
personally think it's wrong that they
have these kids on the show kids deserve
privacy and I think back to my childhood
and maybe some of the embarrassing silly
or goofy things that I did I I would
never want the entire world to see that
that's a private thing but yet parents
are now broadcasting this for the world
to see so North Northwest has actually
grown up to be quite funny though so she
shared her thoughts on her mother's look
prior to the me Galla let's pull it up
and I heard you were into the look yeah
well it could be
just could it be a little bit better
just if I had a bra yes okay what what
are your notes on the dress you saw but
first of all such a compliment this is
the first time North ever said oh wow
that's beautiful I never said oh
wow hi bubs that face I love it what
okay so what are your notes
there's way too much gaps in the pearls
I think we felt the same yeah we felt
looks like she's a Hawaiian girl with
her dress all ripped okay so if we fix
the Pearls by the leg cuz those were all
restrung for us the pearls look fake no
no I think you're wrong here these are
very expensive real pearls I think you
need a lesson on pearls we're not going
for like flapper girl we're going for
like vintage
authentic pearly girly it's looking like
be
okay so that's why we cover I got a
shout out guys I didn't even know this
the stomach so it doesn't look beachy
it's like the diamonds
it this is my worst nightmare
like come to
life I like the pearls I just don't like
that it looks like from the dollar
store it's like I'm being punked the
night before the Met getting read for
Filth by a 9-year-old
okay I respect your opinion please just
be easy on me today okay I am I'm not
going to lie I won't say it at all if
you don't want me to well I'm not going
to lie there's a way to be honest and
not hurt people's feelings so I want you
to learn that because there's a way to
say you know I might not love that you
know I might not love your necklace or
your
outfit everything whoa nice purse what
you got in there what the heck wait what
it's just kind of cringe it is cringe
Jared let killed it Pete Davidson hate
it hate it you're going to the m Gala
Pete not the gas
station North is her father's daughter
that that she is so dang cute that was
actually a nice video um you know what's
interesting how she's basically telling
her mom to cover
up how is your 9-year-old telling you to
cover up Kim Kim it's time to put the
boobs away it's time to put all of this
you're like 40 something it's it's time
it's time okay um so the comment section
weighs in honesty is what you women ask
for but it is not what they want
intelligent girl yeah that's a funny
thing she immediately says it's how you
say it women we never want the truth but
when the men give us the truth are now
her child we can't accept it um having
your father's mindset with your mother's
sass is a crazy work we love North you
can't ask a child to be honest and when
they're honest you get offended you know
what's interesting I heard yay talk
about this a couple of years ago how
it's like we almost all start as
children and we're all honest and blunt
and like when you hear kids talk to each
other it's so funny they're not
political they just say it exactly how
it is and then they get older and the
world starts to socialize them to be so
political and not say what they think I
don't know I just I love watching videos
of kids um okay so guys let me know what
you think in the comment section and
vote by liking your favorite comment
below as you know every episode we read
the top comment from the last video so
today's top comment from last episode is
unfortunately in recent years people
think if they shout loud enough they win
the argument because they don't want to
hear it they could be wrong yes okay
guys let me know what you guys think in
the comment section below like the video
on your way out get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt and sign up for
my email list in case we get kicked off
of YouTube I'll talk to you next time